I got a rash on day eight post chemo and still haven't now on day 13 it's very itchy and sore
covers 90% of me. Oh my goodness. Are you familiar with rashes from chemo? So yes, it's very common
to get rashes from chemo. They have different syndromes that they've called it.
Handed foot disease or something like that. Because your body is
or detoxeted and you get a reaction. So there's different thoughts to why you get rashes
after chemo. Is it your body detoxines or the skin? That's causing the rash. Is it because
you're basically having an allergic histamine type reaction to the chemo? That's a possibility.
So number one, is there something I could have done to prevent it? Not really? No? Did I detox not
enough or maybe too much? Or should a hook-simer reaction? The answer is no, that's not a
hook-simer reaction. So a hook-simer reaction is a reaction to cell death where you have endotoxins
and you're reacting to endotoxins, typically, like a polysaccharides, that's not. So that's not
what it is. But did I not detox enough? Well, again, you don't have full control over your ability
to detox. You're just trying to support your detox pathways. That's why after you're 48 hours,
when you're trying to get the chemo out of you, you're doing coffee enemas, you're doing
gastroepax, you're supporting your liver detox pathways with different supplements. You do everything
you possibly can. It doesn't mean that you're going to triple your detox pathway, the rate of detox
ification by doing x, y, and z. There's no way that you can physically measure those things.
You see the outcomes of our lack or ability or disability and detoxifying. In this case,
this would be one of them, but you just do your best you possibly can. There's no magic thing
that's going to make this all go away. So you just continue to do the best thing you possibly can.
Increase your eye and pro waves to a daily. Increase your coffee enemas. You know,
you asked this question of max gerson 50 years ago, he'd say you should be doing five coffee enemas
a day. If you're you're really seen in inability to detoxify. So everybody has a different rate of
detoxification that is often is almost always beyond your control. So you just try to do your best
to help stimulate that. So increase the number of coffee enemas would be a big thing to do.